vamos ahora a repasar todas las noticias
de la economía internacional ya nos
acompaña en el estudio Daniela Blandón
Buenos días bienvenida Hola buenos días
rodosa Muchas gracias a ti Daniela
empezamos por una noticia Y es que que
tiene un importante ángulo económico y
es que se reúnen los líderes de Estados
Unidos y Reino Unido y exactamente la
economía es protagonista del encuentro
Claro que sí el Primer Ministro
británico Ricci sunak ya está en
Washington y más tarde tendrá su cuarto
encuentro cara a cara con Joe biden
aparte del tema natural que por supuesto
es la guerra en Ucrania se espera que
discutan otros como las tecnologías
emergentes concretamente la discusión
tocará la seguridad de la Inteligencia
artificial según anunció Downey Street
que organizará la primera Cumbre
internacional sobre este asunto en otoño
para discutir Cómo se puede mitigar esos
riesgos conjuntamente
sí Daniela en un momento en que La
regulación de la Inteligencia artificial
preocupa no a gran parte del mundo pero
precisamente esta reunión entre biden y
Richie sunat llega en un momento en que
Reino Unido no atraviesa su mejor
momento Pues es que estamos hablando
rosa de la primera y de la sexta
Economía del mundo y de dos grandes
protagonistas del grupo de los siete sin
embargo Reino Unido es el más rezagado
Dentro de este grupo según la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económicos la ocde ese país
ocupará el poco honroso primer lugar en
la inflación más alta entre las grandes
economías entre 2023 con un 6,9% anual
así lo cuentan desde Londres Luis ha
Pulido y Anita montando
Pablo vi desde hace 10 años en Londres y
trabaja tiempo completo los últimos dos
ha tenido que ser creativo para hacer
rendir su salario impactado por una
inflación anual que ronda los dos
dígitos en realidad ahora Estamos
comprando más marcas del supermercado
las más baratas y cocinando un poco más
básico estamos comprando un poco menos
de carne quizás
Estamos buscando los las ofertas
Valentina y su pareja También tienen un
trabajo estable sin embargo el aumento
de los precios de los alimentos debido
al alto costo de producción del
transporte de la caída en la cosecha de
países productores y los efectos del
brexit ahora compra productos de menor
calidad sí Para ser honesta hemos
recortado mucho porque hemos notado Un
aumento en los precios de todos los
alimentos básicos solo artículos como
mantequilla queso leche normalmente
intentaríamos comprar productos
orgánicos para estar en el lado más
saludable pero finalmente tuvimos que
recortar de muchas maneras solo
alimentos básicos como huevos y queso
ahora volvemos al mínimo que podemos en
el templo de Kensington ubicado en el
vecindario exclusivo de
de casas evaluadas en millones de
dólares se ven filas de ciudadanos que
acuden a buscar alimentos y artículos de
aseo un hecho poco común hasta hace poco
en Londres al pastor Eddy le preocupa
que en el 2020 llegaban al menos 20
personas en la actualidad reciben las
80s
no mejorado se ha vuelto más desafiante
familias enteras están siendo
desalojadas en Londres los propietarios
están subiendo el alquiler todo tipo de
cosas es todo el efecto de la bola de
nieve Así que mirándose delante soy
optimista
mientras el gobierno británico Busca
alternativas para aliviar la crisis se
estudia un acuerdo con los supermercados
para que reduzcan los precios de los
alimentos básicos incluso a Costa de
sacrificar parte de sus ganancias
Daniela y seguimos en Europa pero vamos
a la eurozona Y es que entró en recesión
técnica Qué significa esto exactamente
claro vale la pena hacer algo de
pedagogía antes de comenzar y es que
esta definición de recesión técnica se
usa a menudo en las discusiones
políticas y económicas cuando una
economía soporta dos trimestres
consecutivos de declive esta es una mala
señal Sí pero en muchos casos para
asegurar que hay una recesión
propiamente se tienen en cuenta muchos
otros factores como el empleo y en el
caso europeo hay cierta tranquilidad
porque la inflación se ha venido
desacelerando y el desempleo está en su
nivel más bajo desde antes de la
creación del euro en 1999 exactamente
fue del 6,5% en abril ahora por qué se
entra en recesión técnica porque
eurostat que es el departamento de
estadística acaba de revisar la cifra de
crecimiento del pib para el cuarto
trimestre de 2022 y el primer trimestre
de 2023 como vemos en el gráfico estaban
rozando el 0% en su estimación en de
mayo pero ahora hacen digamos un alza a
la baja Perdón una revisión a la baja
junio en este mes y para el primer
trimestre 2023 y para el cuarto
trimestre 2022 se dice que la economía
bajo un
0,1% esto de todas maneras no deja de
ser cifras eso es un número y no cambia
lo que los hogares ya están
experimentando que es aumento todavía
alto de los precios sobre todo de los
alimentos intereses más altos en
créditos e hipotecas y una lucha porque
los salarios se mantengan al día con el
aumento del costo de vida Daniela pues
gracias por esta explicación y cambiamos
de tema y de región vamos a Estados
Unidos donde muchos estudiantes están en
vilo precisamente por sus créditos Claro
pues el pago de préstamos estudiantiles
federales recordemos a Estados
suspendido desde el comienzo de la
pandemia pero ese salvavidas se está a
punto de ser retirado Y es que dentro de
la negociación que dio lugar a la ley
que suspende el límite de deuda uno de
los logros de los republicanos fue que
no habrá más extensiones de ese programa
y que los estudiantes van a tener que
retomar sus pagos paralelamente el
gobierno biden dentro de su ley de
reducción de inflación propuso la con de
deudas y el miércoles vetó una propuesta
republicana que anulaba esa iniciativa
el departamento de Educación cree que
con este panorama los prestamistas se
atrasarán a niveles históricos porque
pues también hay unas tasas de interés
altísimas y les va a tocar empezar a
pagar otra vez bueno veremos como avanza
toda esta cuestión Daniela pero mientras
tanto pasamos América Latina porque
salieron datos de inflación de Colombia
y Brasil claro fue una alentadores
relativamente en Colombia la cifra
interanual de inflación se desaceleró
hasta el 12,36% en mayo esto es menos de
lo que se veía meses atrás cuando se
llegó un pico de más de dos décadas con
casi un 14%, Pero también es mucho más
alta que hace un año cuando la variación
de los precios era del 9% anual el
presidente Gustavo Petro destacó que los
precios de los alimentos hubieran bajado
frente a abril sin embargo siguen
estando 15% más altos que hace un año si
se hace esta compa ahora en Brasil la
situación es menos dramática su
inflación anual en mayo fue del 3,94%
que es una de las más bajas de la región
atribuida a la caída de los precios de
los combustibles también de los
artículos para el hogar muchos analistas
coinciden en que Brasil ha sido un caso
de éxito Con su política monetaria Por
qué Porque comenzó a subir muy temprano
sus tasas de interés frente a sus
vecinos y hoy en día las tienen su nivel
más alto de desde 2016 eso le ha
permitido bajar la inflación pero el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
también ha llamado reiteradamente a que
bajen esas tasas de interés Daniela pues
vamos a continuar conversando de esto en
nuestra segunda Crónica de economía nos
vemos más adelante más adelante le quedó
debiendo la cifra del día eso